imagine babies grown in
Labs it sounds like a Sci-Fi
cliche but a groundbreaking team of
experts across Europe are hoping to
build the world's first clinically
approved artificial womb in order to
save the lives of babies born
prematurely with nearly a million dying
every year the race is on time is really
of the essence because we quickly have
to provide the infant with
oxygen James was born at exactly 24
weeks he was really very very
tiny when he got my pinky fingernail it
was with his whole
hand in 2012 Sona son James was born
prematurely and like many premature
babies he was put in an
incubator the doctors told us his chance
of surviving was
50% an incubator is a very hostile
environment tragically James died two
months later while incubators save many
lives half of those born at 24 weeks do
not survive in incubators
this is partly because their lungs
aren't yet sufficiently formed to
breathe
air an environment more similar to the
womb is I think the best solution we
wish to help the parents and children
who came after us and that's exactly
what SAA is now trying to
do since 2020 SAA has been an Advisory
Board member to an elite team of
scientists and Engineers they're taking
on an extraord ordinary challenge
constructing an artificial womb what we
really need is an liquid filed
environment that protects the baby from
Air that would be a wish come
true welcome and I think we can start
the program according to the agenda
which is now on the professor France
vavosa leads the team hoping to make
that wish a reality the part of our work
package is to find alternatives for the
birth procedure coordinated by the
einhoven University of Technology in the
Netherlands the approach is innovative
it's as much mathematical as medical my
background is is is not in medical
Sciences my background is in physics how
does our oxygenator work the 29 strong
team includes Global experts in
computational modeling and Industrial
design as well as pregnancy and child
birth the main challenge here is that
the liquid fi Chambers lay is not
conductive and these in this unique
group each collaborator has different
skills they are united by the goal of
Designing and building a womb that
replicates the conditions inside a real
one good modeling is the key to success
here we predict weather by making a
model of the Stratosphere by using
mathematical models we want to predict
what will happen in this case for the
cardiovascular system of the baby inside
the Womp of the mother other projects in
this field are tested by placing baby
animals such as Lambs in bags of
liquid but this EU funded team is using
a very different Beast silicone
rubber we can hopefully postpone animal
experiments for a while by making
mannequins that help us to mimic and
simulate like a flight simulator what is
happening in the
system Juliet Von Haren is in charge of
Designing the
mannequins you see see basically the
range of motions that we can achieve
using these flexures and the motors that
we have embedded in our uh
mannequin what I find very interesting
about this project is that it is at the
intersection of art design um and
biology
engineering one of the big challenges of
this project is finding a way to safely
transfer the fetus from the mother to
the artificial
womb but the team believe they have
found an answer a liquid tunnel so the
infant moves from liquid into
liquid once the baby is inside the
liquid tunnel the umbilical cord can be
cut then after the baby reaches the
artificial womb things get even more
challenging the umbilical cord has to be
quickly reattached this time to an
artificial placenta if this takes more
than a few minutes lack of oxygen will
damage the baby's
[Music]
brain
if all goes smoothly the baby will spend
the next four weeks receiving all its
required oxygen and nutrients through
the artificial placenta and
womb the hope is that more premature
babies will survive in these liquid
filled polymer bags compared with being
in an incubator it should be easier for
their lungs to grow enough to be able to
breathe air weeks later when the baby is
around 28 weeks they can be safely
placed in an incubator before being
finally released to their parents
care but to build a fully functioning
artificial womb the team has to overcome
other potentially fatal risks not least
blood
clotting the main problems we have now
is blood tends to coregulate if it comes
in contact with materials that are not
owned by the body
itself with so many obstacles to
overcome it could be at least a decade
before before this technology is rolled
out to make a difference in the
world what's more it won't be cheap
initially and what about dystopian fears
of opening the door to Growing babies
entirely outside the human womb the team
are adamant that their technology cannot
be used in this way the idea that you
could use maybe the system from the
start to the end the technology is not
suitable for earlier situations we want
to save children and that's the goal of
the
[Music]
project hello I'm Tom standage Deputy
editor at The Economist if you'd like to
learn more about this topic click on the
link opposite and if you'd like to watch
more of our now and next series click on
the other link thanks for watching and
don't forget to
subscribe